[Music]
you are watching the press preview the
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the daily
mirror columnist susie boniface and
assistant comment editor at the daily
telegraph madeline grant and they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
the times leads on the foreign office
telling british nationals to leave
ukraine after the u.s warned that russia
could invade within days
that story is also on the front of the
daily mail
and it's the lead for the mirror which
has the headline get out
that message also makes the front of the
daily express
the ft reports on talks between the u.s
and its allies over ukraine as president
biden fears an attack from russia is
close
the daily telegraph quotes the u.s
president's national security adviser
who said russia could invade ukraine any
day now
leading on a different story the eye
says senior conservatives have warned
the prime minister to not hold on to
power if the police investigation finds
he broke covid laws
and the guardian reports that the
treasury is pushing for most free covet
testing to be scrapped to save billions
of pounds
and reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by daily
mirror columnist susie boniface and
assistant comment editor at the daily
telegraph madeline grant welcome to you
both uh good to see you let's start with
the mail
front page and that uh warning to to
brits to leave get out now
now underlined susie
yes um so
the all the newspapers seem to be in
agreement that there is an imminent
invasion in ukraine and this seems to
come out really as a result of a world
leaders video call that was called by
joe biden who seems to have shared
probably military intelligence with
other world leaders saying that the
troop builds up and everything else
means something is very imminent is
going to happen fairly soon
um and what we do know about the british
citizens who would be in ukraine is
there people who are there because
they've married or because they've got
family ties they're quite deep into the
country they're not just there working
or something and can get out easily
they're not going to want to to run away
they're going to want to stay with their
families
so they may not wish to leave
necessarily
i was speaking to a ukrainian uh
yesterday who said that there's just no
concern about this in the country the
ukrainian leaders said that what biden
has said is nothing particularly new
uh and they seem to just their tone of
their sort of social media feeds is very
much that this is all going swimmingly
as far as they're concerned there's
american and uk troops helping them out
with things they're being supplied with
arms they don't have great concern of
course all that depends upon the fact
that that nato and the west don't
abandon the 40 million ukrainians to
vladimir putin and what we do need to
remember of course is that ukraine is
not part of russia it was once part of a
soviet republic but it's not part of the
russian federation and if putin does
invade he's invading a country on the
edge of europe uh and if you let him do
that
what happens next he seems to think that
he has control over that place or he
should have control over it the people
who live in ukraine disagree with him on
that point
and they speak ukrainian not russian
they have ukrainian traditions not
russian traditions so if nato does
abandon them and say well mr putin you
can you can roll your tanks over there
if you like but you know we'll be
terribly cross with you if you do which
seems to be about the limit of what the
western leaders are saying they're going
to do there'll be some
there'll be some sanctions there'll be
some concerns there'll be condemnation
you know but basically they're just
saying that please don't do it we'd be
cross with you
i don't know if that's necessarily going
to stop him if that's what he wants to
do in that call of leaders with with
nato and the european leaders the prime
minister said an invasion would be
devastating and destructive and down in
australia said that he's insisted it
must be absolutely clear that there will
be a heavy package of economic sanctions
ready to go should russia attack so
that's the warning should there be an
incursion into ukraine
madeline
yes absolutely and and also um
interestingly um we've had we've had
interventions from various ukrainian
diplomats who've been saying that
actually it would be better if they were
to immediately publish the extent of
these sanctions to make to really ram it
home very clearly to moscow what they
could expect um in the event of
proceeding with this this kind of action
but today's been a day where as susie
rightly says that the tone remains
pretty much the same in ukraine but the
tone of all the world leaders and and
many of the dignitaries seems to have
seen a dramatic shift today um what we
saw at we we saw that very much at the
white house press conference earlier
today and even though jake sullivan joe
biden's national security adviser went
to great lengths to say that you know uh
this wasn't sort of um imminent invasion
shouldn't be taken as a certainty that
this was more a case of them preparing
for every eventuality there's no doubt
that when you start um
potentially withdrawing diplomats and
you start warning nationals to get out
of there immediately for their own
safety and this suggests things have got
very seriously indeed and cannot help
but um spark you know greater panic
within ukraine and it's one of those
occasions where we
you know you really have to hope that
the intelligence on this has is out on
this occasion because the implications
for ukraine and its people are truly
horrific
yes and and jake sullivan also making
mention of the fact that um
you know means to to leave the country
might not be open uh for much longer and
there could be an incursion within days
i mean it does seem
that there has been some intelligence to
to allow him to say that and there is
some some movement some sense of urgency
now susie would you agree
yeah and you know joe biden's the one
with the satellite so if he if he thinks
that i'm gonna take it
because i was red because i can't see
that but we also know that um
the russian army while it's very big is
not a very good army it's mostly
conscripts and at the moment there a lot
of them are fly camping they're under
canvas they're in bad conditions and
they're on the edge of ukraine there's a
lot of them
if they don't go fairly soon into
ukraine morale is not going to hold up
to enable putin to move them in any
force for mana in another couple of
weeks if he's going to go he's got to go
in the next week or so
so that's why we're entering this period
of sort of maximum danger if you like if
the west can do enough just to make him
hesitate or or hang around for a bit
longer then the moment may pass and it
may be that we can just sort of just by
being worried almost we can push him
slightly back from the brink and get it
to the point where he can't actually get
cold chilly
depressed conscripts to do the things
that he would need them to do the moment
he can do it and you know he's obviously
using a lot of rhetoric but you know
putin's got a lot of things to distract
from at home as well as a million people
from in russia have died from covert
there's very poor uptake of the vaccine
the sputnik vaccine which he half inched
from the rest of the world uh doesn't
work very well so he's got lots of
things to cover up and he he doesn't
really want a big war with the west but
afghanistan and our shockingly bad
withdrawal from there shows that the
west isn't prepared to go and fight wars
anymore to protect
uh our borders or our own safety so
you know he's he's gambling to some
extent that he's going to be allowed to
roll into ukraine without anything more
than a harsh word
and i think does happen that you know
the west isn't going to be able to to
hold him to that they're going to have
to react
madeleine the big question is what does
vladimir putin want exactly
yes indeed that that is that that is the
question and that his his policy his
sort of approach to warfare of the the
hybrid approach whereby you would deploy
ground troops but all other of uh manner
of other tactics all at once it proves
deeply confusing to western observers
but susie's absolutely right that the
only real
um the best deterrence that we have are
serious shows of strength and proper
economic sanctions and so far there has
been some strengthening of the sanctions
from the british side um but to make it
truly explicit um would would go further
as well as clamping down properly which
is something we have
avoided thus far
clamping down properly on the kind of
dirty money that um ciphers its way
through
london and
potentially going after some of the the
kind of lower level oligarchy that are
allowed to thrive
in london but in other other cities in
europe and and in america and further
afield um it seems that you know there
are further things that could be done
that aren't simply military
uh to the times world pages are inside
the newspaper um this uh interesting
article just
suggesting that giving up warheads has
left ukraine weak uh this is a cold war
general comment piece
susie yeah so the reporter anthony lloyd
has done a great job he's found a
ukrainian general he used to be
sort of maintaining the missiles the
nuclear missiles which were based in
ukraine they had like the third largest
stockpile in the world
after they collapsed the soviet union
and it kind of
you know in terms of the mutually
assured deterrent it kept everybody at
bay and it also meant that ukraine had
an importance on the world stage now in
the mid 90s the uk and uh russia agreed
to sort of
that this stockpile would be disbanded
and done away with and that ukraine
would be a non-nuclear country from then
on and part of all that according to
anthony was that um that ukraine was
going to be sort of you know
not it was going to be safe from all
sides but they're saying that because
they gave up those missiles that's why
putin now sees them as a pawn in his
great game of expansionism against the
west and nato and that's what you've got
here is you've got one country russia
trying to be bigger than it is now and
as big and important as it used to be
trying to be a superpower again you've
got nato which some people want to act
like a superpower but which isn't it's
made up of lots of different groups that
want to do different things and they're
arguing over a country of 40 million
people those people don't want to be
russian they don't want to be
anything particularly they want to be
ukraine
sorry to interrupt you but we must take
a break now i fear uh we're going gonna
get much more from you after the break
coming up how boris johnson might defend
himself over an alleged party in his
downing street flat
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me daily mirror
economist susie boniface and assistant
comment editor at the daily telegraph
madeleine grant welcome back to both of
you let us have a look at the eye um and
this i've got to read out this this
quote first of all um that will pop up
hopefully on the screen other colleagues
astonished by his survival say if i ever
get invited to his funeral i'm going to
lift the lid on that coffin to make sure
he's in there because i'm not convinced
he will be
who are we talking about
starter for ten madeleine
could it be the prime minister that
we're talking about i mean it's a
wonderful quote from the eye um it's
it's just a tory colleague of the prime
minister who's simply astonished at his
capacity for survival um and it's it's
really it's really interesting because
you know it's
things move are moving very quickly in
politics at the moment but it wasn't
long ago that you know even a couple of
weeks ago that the prime minister's
position looked completely untenable not
just in the long term but but in the
short term too
um but in fact as
people very often say of boris johnson
he's a an extraordinarily lucky
politician and so far various things
have happened uh which have helped him
and have made the rebellion lose steam
things like christian wickford crossing
floor
yesterday's attack from john major which
probably played into his hands um and
also an attempt to change the rules of
the 1922 committee to make it easier to
depose him um so on that basis you know
boris johnson and his old luck seems to
be surviving um but interestingly um
some senior tories including um the
former leader in duncan smith have uh
have have warned the prime minister
against trying to cling onto power again
if he is found by the met police to have
broken curved laws and receives a fine
for it so it's a reminder that even
though the position which seemed to be
stabilizing a little bit is still
fundamentally extremely wobbly and um
the intervention from
oh i think we've lost her in duncan
smith is a good reminder that he's some
way out
we lost you for a second there madeline
just to bring out susie in you've got
about 30 seconds uh the telegraph tells
us that
boris johnson is to deny breaking any
law at that infamous party
well of course he is he's denied
everything so far i don't not entirely
sure what the the power of the
conservative party is going to be to
control him though because i'm i don't
think he necessarily considers himself
to be a member of it he's never been
particularly beloved by the
parliamentary party he's not a sort of a
natural tory despite some of his
background
and i think at the moment he's doing
everything he can to buy off some of his
back benches to win their support for
their